[Music]
welcome back so we've been talking about
the singular value decomposition and I'm
excited to show you a number of codes
that walk through these concepts of
dimensionality reduction and coordinate
transformations in both MATLAB and
Python so all of the codes that I'm
going to talk about are on our website
at databook UW comm in both in both
MATLAB and in Python so chapter 1 on the
SVD follows the sections from this book
data driven science and engineering by
myself and Nathan Coates and now I'm
gonna walk you through the Python code
for each of these each of these sections
and this is Python code that was written
by Daniel Daluz key so I'm gonna walk
you through these ipython notebooks
these Jupiter notebooks that that that
he developed based on this material ok
great so you can download all of this
code and all of this data online and
here we go ok so the first video lecture
the first Python code I'm going to walk
you through is how to do image
compression as a really really simple
example of how to use the SVD so
remember we have a matrix X and we're
going to decompose this as some u times
Sigma times V transpose and what we
might do is we might approximate this
matrix this is the singular value
decomposition we might approximate this
by some low rank product u sub R times
Sigma sub R times V sub R where this is
the first are columns of the U matrix
from the SVD this is the first are
columns of the V matrix and this is the
first r by r sub block so this is what
you call a rank R approximation of X and
that's how we're going to approximate
images so for example if this X was a 2d
image of a person or a coffee cup or a
dog then we would try to approximate
this image X as the product of a few
columns a handful of our columns and
times a handful of our rows and this
would be a compression because in
that of storing all of these n by M rows
and columns I just have to store R so
that's what this this code is going to
do so I'm going to move my code back
there okay good so we're always gonna
load numpy as NP and matplotlib as plot
so that we can easily use those commands
in those in those libraries and we're
going to import matplotlib image into
image read so we're sorry we're going to
import the image read command from
matplotlib so that we can we can use it
to load our image here okay so the first
thing is super simple we're going to
load an image of my dog mordecai a jpg
image so image read into this matrix a
and it's a full-color image so it's
actually n by m by three color channels
and so we're going to convert it to
grayscale so that's essentially what
this is going to do here is take the
average over that third channel to make
a grayscale x matrix we're gonna plot
the image and in general when you plot
notice here i have em show 256 minus x
that's because the way I'm getting this
black background is I did a hard invert
on my laptop's colors and so I'm
subtracting 256 my image from 256 to
invert it you would just do in show of X
you don't need that 256 - okay we're
gonna use a gray color map and so on and
so forth so let's just run this and we
should see an image of my dog Mordecai
pop up that's Mort okay Mort the snow
dog he's playing in the snow here okay
so that's Mort and now what we're gonna
do is we're gonna take this array which
essentially is our data matrix X and
we're going to compress it we're gonna
factor it into the cds unitary matrices
U and V and it's diagonal matrix Sigma
and then we're going to approximate more
at different ranks rank five
and 20 stuff like that okay good so oh
yeah and he's actually taller than just
his head so now we're getting to this
SVD part okay so in Python the SVD is
also very very simple so in numpy Lynn
Alves VD you take in this matrix X and
this option here full matrices equals
false that's basically saying you want
to do the economy SVD so instead of
returning a u matrix that's n by n huge
and V that's also square we're just
going to return the first M columns of U
the first M columns of U corresponding
to the nonzero singular values okay
so computing the SVD is super simple
then we're going to extract out the
diagonal singular values from this s
matrix and then what we're going to do
is can essentially construct these
low-rank approximation Zhan Mort at rank
five 20 and 100 and we're gonna see how
good those matrix approximations are and
you can see here it's really simple you
just take the first R columns of U times
the first R by our block of Sigma times
the first R columns of V transposed and
that's your X approximation so these are
just matrix multiplications here okay
and then we're just going to plot those
approximations at rank five rank 20 and
rank 100 let's do that okay so this is
the rank five approximation of my dog
and you can tell that it's not perfect
but you can actually see a lot of the
relevant features you can see kind of
the nose the eyes the ears even the the
stripes on his back so I know it's my
dog rank five and rank 20 this is
obviously a dog like it's very clear
that this is a picture of a dog in fact
it's not just a dog it's my dog you can
tell that this is Mort I could pick him
out of a lineup even from 28 modes so
that's only keeping the first 20 columns
of U use of our
and the first 20 columns of V and
there's a Sigma in here
there's the Sigma R by R multiplying in
there as well to scale all of these
columns so that they add up to the right
the right dog and by the time we get to
a hundred rank approximation it's
actually extremely faithful
representation of Mart you can see like
the glint is I and you know individual
freckles and is in his pelts and things
like that okay so a hundred rank
approximation is really really good and
this is I think about only storing
twelve percent of the original data so
if you only stored the first hundred
columns of U and V in the first hundred
diagonal elements of Sigma that would be
something like an eight times
compression of this data matrix X and
you still have very faithful
reconstruction of more so I think that's
pretty cool
there okay and then what we can also do
is we can plot the singular values so I
would always recommend when you have a
new data matrix X and you compute its
SVD you always want to plot the singular
values these diagonal elements of Sigma
and I usually plot them in a log plot
log Sigma J versus J right here and not
only do i plot the the log of the
singular values but I also plot the
cumulative sum of the singular values I
basically the sum of all of the Sigma
J's from J equals 1 to R divided by the
sum of all of the singular values from J
equals 1 to M and so what this tells you
is kind of the fraction of the energy
captured by the first are modes okay so
it should go up to 1 this is kind of 100
percent of the energy or 1 and in rank R
this tells you how much of the of the
matrix is captured by those first
hormones and so this is the the log
singular values for Mort and this is the
cumulative energy in those singular
values and you can see this is kind of
exactly what I want in a data matrix is
notice this is on a log scale there's a
lot of there's a lot of energy in the
first very
few motes this is the first maybe ten or
twenty modes and that's capturing a
large fraction of the energy these
singular values are much much larger
than all of these and what that means is
that I can get away with keeping only
these first few and throwing away a lot
of the remaining singular values and
truncating and you can also see that in
this cumulative plot here where even
just keeping the first singular vector
captures about 30% of the energy and
then very rapidly we get up to 70 80 90
% just with the first you know 50 or 100
modes okay so even though it's a
high-res image I don't actually need to
keep all of that information I can I can
compress it using the singular value
decomposition okay thank you